Compuptational clusters are the work horses
of giant scale services, any modern data
centers employs on the order of
thousands and thousands of computational nodes connected
by high performance, high speed networks.
It is such computational clusters, which are
serving as the work horses for giant scale services today. And this figure
reproduced from Eddie Gruer's paper circa 2,000 shows
the number of nodes in a data center, maybe
on the order of 1,000. But scale it up by ten or 100 in terms of today's
computation capacity that you might find in a
typical data center. And the kind of volume of
queries that are going to be handled. By
giant scale services today. Each node in the cluster
may itself be an SMP. There are serveral virtues for structuring the
computational resources inside a data center as a cluster of machines connected
by high performance back planes. The
advantages include absolute scalability. You can
keep adding more resources. Without worrying
about re-architecting the internals of the
data center. Cost and performance is another
important issue and that is by having
computational clusters at every node is identical
to others, is that as a system administrator
we can control both the cost, And the performance of running a data center like
that, and because of the independent components
you can easily mix and match generational changes
in the hardware, and the results are incremental
scaleability you add more resources you get more.
In terms of performance because, as I told
you earlier, most of the queries that come
into giant-scale services tend to be embarrassingly parallel.
So the more resources you've got, the more
queries you can handle. There is incremental scalability
when you're using clusters because you can add more
nodes to the cluster, increasing the performance. Or, if the
volume, of request come down, you can scale back. That's
the advantage of using computational clusters as the work horses
for data centers that are serving giant scale services today.